هل تشرب كمية كافية من الماء ، هل
تحافظ على رطوبتك ،
هذه أسئلة شائعة ، ولكن ماذا
عن
هذه الأسئلة ، هل تشرب الكثير من الماء ، هل تشرب الكثير من الماء ،
هذه أسئلة ربما لم تكن
معتادًا عليها ولكن يمكن أن تكون بنفس
الأهمية في حين أنها ليست شائعة أكثر من
الترطيب  يمكن أن تكون مشكلة فعلية
وفي حالات نادرة ، تحدث مشكلة قاتلة
تُعرف باسم نقص
صوديوم الدم ، يحدث نقص صوديوم الدم عندما
يتم تخفيف مستويات الملح في الدم عن المعدل الطبيعي
من شرب الكثير من الماء أو
المشروبات الرياضية.
قد يكون هذا مصدر قلق خاص
للطلاب الرياضيين وأولئك الذين يشاركون
في
رياضات التحمل ، فإن الأعراض
تشبه الجفاف
ولكن زيادة السوائل في هذه الحالة هي
خطأ كبير
يقول الخبراء أن أفضل قاعدة أساسية هي
ببساطة الاستماع إلى
شرب جسمك عندما تكون  عطشان وتوقف ببساطة
عندما لا تكون
كذلك ، سواء كنت في حفلة نيتفليكس أو
تشغل مسافة 10 كيلو ،
فهذه الطريقة ستبقيك رطبًا بشكل صحيح
للدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا ريد بنيون